[Musique]
benoît bry sur marne
ne nous fait pas peur a dit que si j'ai
fait il n'avait pas peur le temps en
principe et vous avez toujours eu peur
oui quand je rentre tard
ce serait vraiment très seul
mademoiselle vous rentrer tous les soirs
prenez l'autobus vous allez loin jusqu'à
la mayenne vous n'avez pas peur je
partirais si vous êtes à quelques
je sais pas
que pensez vous qu'ils cherchent un sac
à main ou pas spécialement aux thèses
mais eu des personnes attaquées par
égoïsme est arrivé quelque soit votre
photo je te jeunes se mettent à rêver et
par des types pas très intéressant bien
sûr mais vous allez vous défendez oui
j'ai eu la chance d'aller un peu plus
loin commissariat le commissaire de
police a arrêté ce type en question qui
était temps d'être acquis puisque je
crois maintenant que vous prenez quand
même certaines précautions et bien je
prends voyez vous j'ai ma chienne déjà
naturellement et ensuite j'ai les clés
dans la main de façon vous voyez la néo
face et dans le monde pousse et ça me
fait quand même beaucoup de poing
américain j'ai lu les journaux
évidemment je fais très attention
je tâche de rejoindre quelqu'un dans la
rue
puisque la chose est bien vrai ce n'est
pas un conte mais il ne s'agit pas même
d'une heure particulière de la journée
puisque nous avons vu dans la rue un
petit peu plus haut une dame seule qui a
été attaqué à 15 heures de l'après midi
vous pensez donc on peut attaquer
n'importe quand et n'importe où est ce
que vous prenez des précautions dès
maintenant oui je prends quelques
précautions c'est à dire que le plus
possible je mets mon porte-monnaie dans
ma poche si j'ai de l'argent et je me
prépare à laisser mon sac sans
résistance en résistance puisque je suis
sûr que je ne serai pas la plus forte
avez-vous je n'allais pas je n'adhère
pas je n'avais aucun et je sais très
bien que si je crie l'eau ce que
personne ne viendra m'aider si je crie
au feu certainement viendra mais si je
crie au secours ne viendra pas parce
qu'en général je trouve que tous les
gens sont prêts peureux et vous prenez
le bus tous les soirs madame vous n'avez
pas peur de vous faire attaquer la nuit
ça fait rien comment ça fait rien ça
paie rien pendant qu'une fois vous savez
c'est pas toujours c'est pas toujours
pour mourir d
[Musique]